-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Eric Trump took
the witness stand today
in the Trump Organization's
$250 million civil fraud trial.
Though, does anyone believe they
told Eric what was going on?
[ Laughter ]
What's he going
to testify about?
The magazines
and the outer office?
"Yeah, there was
a 'Car and Driver' from 2009
and some 'Golf Digests,'
I think."
Donald Trump Jr.
took the witness stand yesterday
in Manhattan Supreme Court
and testified
about his various
duties and responsibilities
at the Trump Organization.
His job was to let
his dad slap him
whenever Eric wasn't around.
[ Laughter ]
The Texas Rangers defeated
the Arizona Diamondbacks
last night to win
the World Series,
which came as a shock
to Mets fans
who thought baseball
ended in August.
[ Laughter ]
Fox News host Sean Hannity
had a live show last night
from the Capitol.
Said his viewers,
"Hey, I've been there!"
[ Laughter ]
According to an analysis of his
personal financial disclosures,
House speaker Mike Johnson
does not have a bank account.
He keeps trying to open one,
but no one at the bank
will believe his name
is Mike Johnson.
"It's really my name,
and I really live
123 Main Street!"
That's right.
House speaker Mike Johnson's
personal financial disclosures
show no investments,
bank account or assets.
Though, in his defense,
that's probably the only reason
why George Santos hasn't
stolen his identity yet.
[ Laughter ]
80-year-old Congresswoman
Kay Granger
announced yesterday that
she will not seek reelection
because at that age,
it's time to kick back
and run for president.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that the 2023 Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree
will be an 80-foot-tall,
12-ton Norway spruce
from Vestal, New York,
continuing the long tradition
of coming from upstate
to get in everybody's way.
[ Laughter ]
Celebrity chef Guy Fieri's
line of malt beverages,
Flavortown Spiked,
recently unveiled
a new fruit punch flavor.
"Flavortown Spiked" is also
what he asked for at Supercuts.
[ Laughter ]
In the end, that had nothing
to do with the fact
they have
a new fruit punch flavor.
We need to write jokes
about the news that happened.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
88% of doctors said
it was likely
that patients would receive
some misinformation
when asking AI chat bots
for medical information,
like this guy who's
going through menopause.
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks unveiled
its holiday menu yesterday,
which includes a new
iced gingerbread oatmilk chai,
which is great if you're looking
for something both seasonal
and humiliating
to say out loud.
[ Laughter ]
"I'll just take that new --
the new one.
The -- The new one over there."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
men who picked up
their cellphones
more than 20 times a day
have 21%
lower sperm concentration.
Which begs the question:
what are they picking it up
with?
[ Laughter ]
Hold on. I just got a text.
Wasn't important.
And finally, the footwear
company Crocs has partnered
with McDonald's
to release a new line of shoes.
So now you can show people
you've given up twice.
And that -- that was
a monologue, everybody.